Michels with us in Dallas hi Michelle
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hello hi
what's up well um student loans my son
graduated from college and still looking
for work and all the loans are coming in
like just about like eight every time we
turn around we've got another loan which
we've got to pay it's kind of
overwhelming so I was wondering what is
your sign on the law day my husband did
he co-signed on them oh crap
yeah so what's the balance a balance on
all these ones I was probably over a
hundred thousand good lord yes yes and
he got his migraine yeah um what'd he
get his degree in pardon what did he get
his degree what philosophy yes hey I
guess he thought since he was big in
debate in high school went to state two
years in a row what was your husband
back when he signed up for $100,000 for
a philosophy degree I think he was
thinking you know he wanted his children
to do better because neither one of us
have a college party getting a
philosophy degree was going to cause him
to do better I don't know
I hoping he would change his way of
thinking you know so but we've got all
these loans
he is consolidating good or what can we
do make them go away what what's good is
creating income yeah follow what's jr.
doing what's he make right now my son's
waiting tables looking for work as we
speak you know picking up odd jobs and
can you know trying to help as much as
they can but hours a week is he working
I think he's trying to get he's getting
about 40 hours that's good okay yeah
blending table enough extra shifts and
stuff but right now it's taking my whole
paycheck and I'm a teacher's aide and
it's now taking my monthly paycheck to
pay his lungs yeah so what we have is a
a child who was educated in a field that
doesn't make him very employable right
and so we have to figure out a way we
have to figure out a way for this young
man to get a career track where he can
make a living other than
waiting tables don't we exactly because
he needs to make $100,000 so you don't
have to pay all this back exactly and so
this is a career crisis is what it is
mm-hmm yeah I'm so I'm gonna get very
very practical for the first time in
your household okay start thinking about
how we can turn this kid's education
into an income and I'm gonna start
studying and thinking about a career
track and direction and what he can get
out there and get started on that that
is beyond just a stopgap measure waiting
for you know waiting tables waiting for
his ship to come in and so we need to
identify his ship and he needs to swim
out to it yeah for the first time in his
life and so that that's what you got to
do here because this is a huge mess oh
yes and if he waits tables you're going
to end up paying a hundred grand back
between now in the next ten years and
consolidating is fine but it doesn't fix
it you got a hundred thousand dollar
problem and that that's you know that's
the issue so I'm gonna put you on hold
and Kelly's gonna send him a book called
start because he needs to start this is
the Dave Ramsey show
you
you